[Music]
[Music]
we made tap handles for blood Weiser
Goose Island Miller Lite
you know I think this is a first with an
actual snow globe on tap handle yeehaw
Pale Ale I like this one because it's
just a big awesome looking tap any
steagle Prescott and central waters to
name a few a mark Steinhardt general
manager of ajs tap hands
I definitely would try that beer so a
guy walks into a bar and the first thing
he does if it's me I look what's on tap
certainly the unique fat pebbles piqued
your interest and might push you to try
that beer I like this tap handle because
I'm a little breaker we're located in
random Lake Wisconsin which is about 45
minutes north of Milwaukee
even though Wisconsin is a rural state
we produced tap handles for the mega
breweries on down to the smallest micro
group we believe we're the largest
domestic producer in town
yes we ship out approximately a half a
million cat pendants issue we can
produce the tap metal from start to
finish this is a very detailed tap
handle and I would guess takes about an
hour to hand paint all the detail on it
companies do try to have the most
eye-catching most unique tap handle in
the bar than it is a cross between art
and manufacturing we always say our cap
handle will sell your first beer and
your beer will sell the rest in the cold
white north of Minnesota there's a place
that will get you warm after a long day
on the ice you can do some fishing for
have a tasty beverage
and it's something of a dream for Josie
I've always wanted to own a neighborhood
bar and we finally do mine's just
sitting on a frozen lake ice fishing is
a way of life around here for people it
gets so cold below zero temps quite
often which allows us to dry then put
houses out and drill holes in the lake
and fish when it gets cold enough in the
early winter
Josie's husband goes out and tests the
ice to make sure it's thick enough
[Music]
if it is they can put the bar together
and then the ISIL can open the ice here
is so thick that this bar sits on top of
it to come to our bar on the lake you
just drive your car out on the ice and
park we don't have a parking lot you
just park wherever you want walk in and
have a beer
people like to fish and drink beer and
from our bar here you can do that all at
the same time the local favorite drink
here is called the minnow shot people
will actually take a live middle which
is fishing bait and put it into their
shop and drink it as delicious is that
seafood beverage sounds people come just
because the fact that the bar exists is
pretty amazing
people's reactions to this bar are from
crazy - they don't understand it that's
the coolest thing ever
they come from all over the world to see
it it's very seasonal we're only open 20
days if you're ever near like light a
drive out on the ice Park come into the
bar and grab a pole
[Music]
pubs there's thousands of them but this
story is about just four and what makes
them so special they're old this guy
thinks his pub is oldest and fair bit
older our rights no way I guess we
should look into this in that case
welcome to the search for the oldest pub
in the world take the floor landlord
once welcome to the old trip dilution
the oldest pub in England so the
landlord boards go back to 1760 hoping
other caves go back to 1070 when the
first castle was built up here here is
the wooden galleon don't touch it out
everyone who's cleaned it it's come to a
mysterious end who knows if for the
oldest pub in the world where we shall
serve the best part of the world
[Music]
learn on - you're up welcome to the old
ferryboat the oldest pub in England and
possibly the world is until the last
coaster
no no no it is right this pub has been
dated back to 1050 ad but legend has it
it's 500 years older so it's pretty old
pretty damn old we don't have any silly
ships here but we do have a ghost this
pub was built on the grave of a young
girl for Juliet's but one thing's for
sure we do serve the best point let's
hear it landlord 3 welcome to your man
inside it's so old
we don't even know exactly how old it is
the records go back to 1251 but the
design of our cellar is before the turn
of the century so you don't know it's
definitely older than the others though
right one ghost we've got way more than
that we've got 53 and one in particular
is way better than theirs
in 1651 James Stanley the seventh Earl
of Derby was executed right here during
the English Civil War ed oldest pub in
the world we think so but one thing's
for sure we pull the best pint in the
world wait I haven't introduced up you
there
there are many who claim to be the
oldest but we are fully researched and
dated as the oldest come on in
you're very welcome chance the Barretts
elf is actually older to the town itself
almost all the owners are on record even
back to the original owner Lewin himself
in 900 and he guided people across the
old fort just here over here in the
walls is a letter answered from the
Guinness Book of World Records have we
found it you have found it and you're
very welcome to Shaun's every bearers
got to clear the best beer doors but we
can certainly plan with the best whiskey
in the world this has gotta be the best
excuse for a pub crawl ever
jail
[Music]
[Music]
the body man is our speciality well for
centuries and self in fairly
the unusual is very payment in a this
guy would get dressed up once a year the
China they all the bad luck together
maybe hopefully give him a good harvest
so you touched off with your luck or you
can't eat one of these Reapers and I'll
give you good luck
I'm Andrew Taylor and then the bunny man
I'm so pleased here to reflect obviously
all over a thousand Birds we take the
value we dry them off yeah well out of
my face and they actually saw the
baklava
curtisha and I'm a t-shirt to my toes
and also salt and then they just take
the worst on me pretty much one by one
from head to toe
[Music]
they cut yeah we do this escape yeah you
don't really feel comfortable you sat
down you're uncomfortable you're walking
you're uncomfortable you sort of never
really that comfortable plasma to help
first don't you learn and you come out
that they hold the pose and they they
belong selfies rate but also just make
sure I'm okay because I can't see down
exactly stay ahead
[Music]
what on the horse of beans fairy as much
of that as I can enter streaks war
people they come out with drums or
basket and the job take a step off or
water-ski stops all of it also cleans
ready and then I had the high street
going to all the pubs restaurants for
mr. burski I must warn though 810 male
overall I would see
a clean slate especially we get very
excited on the day of money man you
normal as body man's day they all really
enjoyed all kind of the very parent of
this and asked the traditional not many
people can say they've been the body man
there's only a few that I know all the
happy the body man's of feel safe those
great days be a paradox or tear it up in
the body man no for five years is a very
big honor he informs of Prince fada for
my life may have seen the body man son
son was seven eight year old that do
pass on to hopefully the person takes
over just carries on as fantastic
leadership that's only offer because as
such a unique tradition a year in the
never one that disappear and other at
all fake animal senator always be a
bunny man away from the body
[Music]
our founding fathers were booze hounds
so much so that Benjamin Franklin
published a dictionary of 228 words that
all describe one thing being blind drunk
in the 13 colonies we love to drink
colonial Americans were perpetually
bombed especially since water wasn't
always clean and accessible many of our
nation's most respected men could be
found with a glass or two in hand in
fact Thomas Jefferson drafted the
Declaration of Independence while drunk
on Madeira George Washington racked up
an epic bar tab of over 160 bottles for
just 54 delegates
zone me and John Adams went on a
seven-week binge drinking 6 hours a
night with younger congressmen keep
drinking so Franklin took a stab at his
peers and published the terms to go for
hurt at local pubs in the drinkers
dictionary here's what they said
I've got corns in my head oh go eat a
pudding bag Thomas you're one to talk
Washington you're as dizzy as a goose
I'm shambled my goodness Hamilton you've
got a brass eye today well the king was
his cousin clearly gentlemen you're all
wasted
[Music]
you
[Music]